I feel a little bit awkward sort of
taking credit for I mean there been so
many alcoholics who played alcoholics in
the history of the movie business and I
knew that you know in this day and age
of sort of like celebrities personal
lives becoming news stories those are
questions that I was gonna have to kind
of answer anyway so what was interesting
for me was to be able to define the
story myself the way I see it which is
really one of hope her chair coaching
basketball yeah keeps me busy keeps my
mind off other things yeah what was it
like working with these guys Ben I loved
it you know I really loved it they
reminded me why I got into this in the
first place
they showed up every day it worked hard
they had to work on the basketball that
there was some serious acting work they
had to do and they did it without
complaint they did it with joy they did
it with discipline and I thought like
wow this is the reason I do this it's
very easy to get distracted by all kinds
of stuff you know what they say on
Entertainment Tonight that kind of thing
when it's you know you're very lucky if
you get a chance to do this for a living
it's so I feel I felt very blessed and I
got to make friends with these guys
which was really nice they put me on the
group chat which I feel is a sign of
trust oh yeah you put a little private
jet that's the easy to do okay now in
exchange did you guys teach Ben some of
your dance moves you guys anything about
giving you advice I should say about
being in the business yeah every day we
I would come to set with like a
flashcards and questions like immensely
and I'd be preparing you know I mean you
when you meet a girl you got all these
questions you want to ask and you just
want to find a way to slide in it was
like that we've been is kind of weird is
like a like a broad question was like an
icebreaker type thing like when you
first meet a girl you know yeah you know
they call I love the
you know you never forget as an actor
that those years that you spend
auditioning preparing things going in
get here and weird feedback and non sent
why why didn't I get cast and what do
they want and it's very frustrating it's
very difficult it's very competitive and
there's something really inspiring about
you know these young men who are trying
to do that and it reminded at that time
in my life in I think as an actually you
always sort of think of yourself that
way it's like gotta get the next job
gotta get you know get I hope people
like it you know you're always sort of
at the victor at the mercy of the critic
in some way and so it's fun hearing
about like what kinda stuff they were up
for enjoying their successes seeing them
get other parts you know that was that
was very cool you guys brought so much
emotion in part to the film but I think
a lot of people were doing that for you
too Ben because I would say it was bold
taking on a project that you know your
character has struggles with issues that
you deal with personally so was that
something that influenced you and taking
on this role yeah I mean you know it's
an interesting question because I feel a
little bit awkward sort of taking credit
for me they've been so many alcoholics
who played alcoholics in the history of
the movie business you know many of whom
were quite public about it like and
talked about it our County or Bradley or
whoever it is and I knew that you know
in this day and age of sort of like
celebrities personal lives becoming news
stories those are questions that I was
gonna have to kind of answer anyway so
what was interesting for me was to be
able to define the story myself the way
I see it which is really one of hope I
know and have a lot of friends who have
dealt with various issues like this
compulsive behavior addictive behavior
and the vast majority of them are really
good honest accountable people living
good healthy lives and the idea that
life gets better that you can get better
that you can overcome your obstacles is
a really important one to me and that's
the approach that I liked about this
movie wasn't just well there's
alcoholism
that's kind of ordinary no I'm sure but
Gavin told us he said that you both had
seen the script and you came to him and
said I want to play the lead and I want
you to direct that's absolutely true so
what was it about the script that was
speaking to you and you thought this is
it too soon too close to home no I
really like a full range of kind of
access to my emotions I'm feeling really
ready to do a heavy performance based
piece and I knew that Gavin was both a
really good director for actors and also
has done sports really realistically
with you a miracle on warrior he was
kind of the perfect choice for this and
I was thrilled when he said yes
if God's working on this film
therapeutic Howe said well I think that
there is a certain amount of therapy
that comes along with like emotional
honesty you know III remember
Melvin's first day when he showed up and
he had to show some real vulnerability
and some humility and as manas young men
were not necessarily encouraged were
taught to show that kind of thing and he
did it with bravery and with excellence
and and you know to me that really set
the tone for like okay we're gonna play
this real you know we're gonna we're
gonna be honest about this story and
we're gonna show and we're gonna be
vulnerable and I think you have to be
vulnerable to a certain extent to
generate empathy in the audience if you
hold too much back if you hide
everything if you kind of withhold that
stuff you won't move an audience they
won't care and that's sort of the whole
point of making the movie is bringing an
audience in and generating compassion
and and enthusiasm and and and care for
these characters you felt the
authenticity from start to finish thank
you very much and what about the scripts
appeal to the two of you what spoke to
you yeah the script you know I'll tell
them when I first when they first sent
it to me I kind of tried to like tell
the story before I haven't read II try
to put it things and soon as I open it
in every single page that I turned to
was just like okay you know this the
typical sports movie man and this is
gonna happen
the next page it's like wow this one a
completely different route ya know not
everybody's gonna have the game-winning
shot and everything's gonna be all nice
and dandy it really has some real-life
elements to it right it wasn't entirely
predictable right yeah yeah when the
brighter wrote me a letter when he first
sent me the script it didn't say like
well I think there are things that you
would understand about this movie wait
what he was really interested in was
like the ways in which you kind of
subverted the genre and did things you
didn't expect and surprised the audience
and I think that's really really
important to filmmaking if an audience
can more or less predictable it's gonna
happen anticipate or the outcome is just
a little more boring you know it doesn't
mean you can't enjoy that movie but you
know we want to do things that were
unusually realistic and kind of take the
audience off guard well something else
audiences are looking forward to and the
last dual you're teaming up with the boy
Matt Damon again what are you looking
forward to about that
alright I'm very excited yeah Matt
started shooting this week I'm going on
Saturday or Sunday I guess to to France
I'm a little nervous because I've never
done a medieval it's 1386 so it's like
armor and swords and stuff like that but
you know it was a real pleasure working
with Matt and the Kohala Center who
wrote the script with us and you know I
thought we kept on saying why aren't we
done this you know more often we just
got lucky and our schedules kind of
collide you know intersected so that we
had some free time to share and and we
got Ridley Scott directed and Jodi
comers in the movie it's like you said
in five years you would like to see
yourself in a loving relationship a
stable healthy relationships really what
do you feel are important qualities for
you to have I don't know I think a trust
and care and mutual respect and you know
all the sort of usual stuff but but I
think that's a big part of what makes
life satisfying and interesting you know
so obviously like everybody it's
something that I'm that I'm interested
in and you know it sort of happens what
happens though you know it's not the
kind of thing you can you get force
[Music]